so if you have any inflammation in your
digestive tract whether it's in the
stomach the small intestine or the large
intestine you are going to be very glad
you watch this video because I'm going
to show you a very simple inexpensive
remedy that virtually has zero side
effects that you can use for gastritis
irritation to your esophagus
ulcers and you can also use this for
like a hernia and if you have
diverticulitis or colitis or ulcerative
colitis or even Crohn's any inflammation
in your digestive tract you should try
this remedy you know if you look at the
current
method of treating these conditions one
of the things they do is they use an
antibiotic you know antibiotics have
been pouted as the most incredible
discovery of this Century right well if
that's true they definitely have created
a lot of problems for us and a lot of
people people take antibiotics I mean
each year it's like 73 billion
antibiotics are prescribed I mean if you
do the math I think this comes out too
and I'm correct me if I'm wrong I think
it's like nine or ten antibiotics for
every man woman and child on this planet
that's a lot of antibiotics and the
problem with antibiotics is that they
may kill a good percentage of friendly
bacteria in your gut
but what about those bacteria that
survive right you ever hear the
expression what won't kill you will make
you stronger well that's exactly what
happens when you take antibiotics the
microbes that survive become super bugs
okay they can then release what is
technically called
can of whoop ass on your body they can
create all sorts of problems because the
relationship initially was friendly now
that relationship is not too friendly
okay some of these microbes that did not
create a problem become more pathogenic
in the relationship like E coli and
salmonella and H pylori candida which at
one time you know lived in peace with
your system but now they're very
antagonistic and they can create all
sorts of inflammation in your digestive
system I mean the same thing goes with
eating cancer when someone takes
chemotherapy does it kill all the cancer
cells
maybe it does but usually it doesn't
usually there's a small percentage left
and that percentage whether it's five
percent one percent that's left
changes okay it becomes stronger
and it can come back and be very
resistant to any treatment I mean you
can use a stronger chemotherapy to kill
it off but don't you have also the
immune system that's susceptible to the
same chemicals and now what are you
going to do without your defenses and
this is the same problem that occurs
between countries right if you start
using
nuclear bombs that's going to indirectly
affect you so what I'm going to show you
is something natural that you can use
that virtually has no side effects it's
not going to sterilize your body like
they do with all sorts of pasteurized
food it's not going to diminish the
number of microbes it's not going to
change the relationship of your microbes
to something unfriendly it's going to
help this relationship become stronger
and this remedy actually is
cabbage juice highly researched I found
studies all over the world on this and
I'll put some links down below depending
on how severe your inflammation is like
if it's a minor problem just take one
cup a day if it's a major problem take
like a quart which is four cups or for
those people in Europe a liter but
cabbage juice is very very interesting
I've talked about this in the past of
just eating cabbage for anything related
to digestive problems out of all the
vegetables that people seem to tolerate
when they have gastritis or digestive
problems cabbage seems to be the one
that they can tolerate the best well I
think I know why because it has four
interesting factors that can help the GI
tract number one it has something called
vitamin U it helps increase the speed at
which you can heal these ulcers or
lesions in your GI tract it protects the
mucous layer
in your entire digestive system it also
has anti-erosion factors so anything
that is like inflamed irritated or
destroyed okay and they even use this
now topically on your skin and
apparently it's also good for depression
as well but this vitamin U is also in
other things too like a wheatgrass juice
apparently it's in butter it's in raw
milk and it's an animal fat which is
interesting because if you're on the
carnivore diet and you're consuming a
good portion of animal fat that seems to
help inflammation your gut but of course
pasteurized milk will probably make
things worse because it's sterilized
milk but raw milk apparently has
something in it that can help
inflammation your gut now that's just
one thing in cabbage there's something
else it's called sulforaphane
sulforaphane is also in other things too
like broccoli broccoli Sprouts brussels
sprouts it's another cruciferous
vegetables like cauliflower and Cal and
it's also in Watercress but sulforaphane
is also good for
ulcers that are caused from H pylori and
it's one of the most important triggers
for this other compound called
Nrf2 which you don't need to know the
full name you just need to know that it
helps to detoxify the body it helps as
an anti-inflammatory it's a very potent
antioxidant helps modulate or regulate
an overactive immune system so it tends
to suppress inflammation without
lowering the ability for your immune
system to fight things off and cabbage
is loaded with vitamin C I did a video
on this talking about leaky gut and
leaky gut really is kind of the
subclinical version of scurvy because if
you think about
scurvy in other parts of your body like
your gums you have bleeding gums and
what's happening is it's affecting the
collagen or the connective tissue if
there's like holes in this area and
things don't join tightly like
especially in the gut then you start
getting a leaking situation or holes in
your gut or your teeth and you see like
a bleeding gums so whatever happens in
the gums can happen in your colon okay
and then you start having particles get
through there and then your immune
system reacts to that and we start
having all sorts of inflammatory issues
that just so happens that cabbages load
with vitamin C and cabbage juice has one
more thing which is pretty cool
L-glutamine now what does L-glutamine
well L-glutamine is a very common remedy
for inflammation in your gut it's also
good for a leaky gut situation and
anything related to inflammation in the
colon L-glutamine can help you and now
glutamine also can do other things too
it can help reduce
ammonia now if you think about just H
pylori and if it's going to create an
ulcer it will as a strategy create more
ammonium to raise the pH of the stomach
so it can survive better those four
things are very potent in cabbage juice
and what you want to do is you want to
take fresh raw organic cabbage juice it
can be either green or red cabbage you
juice it fresh and you drink it down
extremely effective based on the studies
I'll put down below virtually no side
effects I mean honestly it's really the
ideal situation where you have this
great remedy which is totally
inexpensive anyone can do it you do need
a juicer okay but other than that it's I
think the ideal solution now that's the
solution but it's also important to
understand what originally created this
inflammation and then also data on what
to eat and what foods to avoid going in
the future to support the microbiome
because we want this very diverse
plentiful microbiome to support your
digestive system and we want to know the
foods that are best for this so for that
video you should watch this right here